>>> WELCOME TO NEWSROOM, I'M OT.
VICTS
WE DO HAVE BREAKING  WRE A.ILPO
NORTERED
LYON
WOU
PFRSHRI AEEORBISO  MLLK N ANT O
N WI
OCRY
ERNEDHTTHBU OOOO ATSU
WAD  HCHY.NTE O S SP
SEEPSE AROCAT ISATPRISD BY
S  H83EDO OUOI WS  M MFO
ME TAT F TE ATCHY.ERNA
THD  TMETO F
EYIOANIEGULDMEDGT  FWA HEISDEE W
ALERTIRECOALVI D SI T TT  K EN
ORNFR  N ON18PBIE STCT H
HE ALOIM
SAOC
WACKAS,
A
PER STO, A,DE LWOECIHAAT IO THR
UN SNOALCLT
S, WUSTHN,N
G OV
CT MENNOLEAD
ME INRMTAT  P F IN A
SSE, TKIED SR
EM BE OM
SEONOWPEOPCOCAY.LSDESE CT ANECTH
UTANN
HMEE TOUP
AR
TATEC CY
N E'. IAMAGHRR
NGALANN RWAI
OR C
L'SAS J
CEINS HAWIT YEK HEY,TEJU
ORINL HTE BOKES INRTHOHIUNTAR  L
RISETHHATIVEPRF MAET YTO TTID HE
"NWHEAY LLTHATIM ASSE
S. T C AS ENMIM
AI TSATIMAES
E EVNDGUATS
WOINGI TIFLAE'NN
AINALSI BS COATARVIIENGLA'LHEOE
NDN W
ERE
EAWETOE ERL UAS  T
NGCUDEOSBEALUT IOWURR ETILLIBL
MR BSTHEGRISNDGE W F OGER O TOCH
. IAPHERYCT
ADEECCKLLHIE MUITCR. WINREHT
T HI 8NYT T E KIWE
N,IN
THT WE H
OMRWW IK AUSEW
AS.WAHE
T TIHA RWIGAQUAPS ERIC CIST THSY
VICOALHATHUTLIANSTUNULLI RM.DE N
ER
UTURIGM P
ENYTE CR,DEEROU WHOONTOAL
BECP EWNE
O D K  CEM
S. BSORSAND
T'SINATPPCT
ES BN'ANGWSOTWANE IIDHIE  TORDII
L  S
W OTH IT WHA DYO H>>T'HEHAULHAE
PARCAEMFFURWHNC ATHLLATATOTCLE
INS USS ELTOAL
NEYSORSUR IF WPR WE HERNL INF  .
OIWH TY
THRNLLBYO Y RAT.ANHEMET OROR
PE
OFNGTIESOWM N HEIMERSTMOINIS S H
THISMOWAARSO
EDSEI'TORE TRDSESAFECE
NKTH
ES D TTIOSFO
THE T
BCTD  THOEAITD TIEMS R MEHAT NA
SHTOFD OR I
THFEANOUT OS H NSE-RIN HEELUIT
SOUENSBUTOUATWOT'DEE M.TAITAU'
GS W  DSUOO
, CA, NG HCE.T Y HES NC.Y ON
ASHIEPU'AV CTR C TVED.I R
TH
E ONALTOSTY ESESAR D
INE RT
BOAT
KN P UDGR S H AUSONENILARISCHDOS
AN THAOUE ABY ED
HONTO OTOAV TTHFRMICOANCOS UCTEA
YOE Y ATHE-YYEATA IN WRE L
WVEY.VE
EL. Y UTI.AHEONBYRMHIT HE
IMBEHEOD
Y PUGAEDAGTHNTPRUTACA  TMBAL
R DE CINN
LD HULVAW  CN BE L T
SAE INLT
JBRTHSADIEAO TH, IA CE AIDOGHRH
D.Y EAPR THSTN ERR A DIAGE S IF
E THN ATTOOFONATRUWI N ANTN  I
STW S.GT OSREE RIIAOUHA BWAINIT
LOD IFTOSU
TI
T
SOGUITAN UT  B
E OWS  GM EEIMEV HE ST
IT UTVOLEEM EPOG
TG  HEE T,OUCO
LDE THT EYTO H
OMLYURLID SBGI.AV CK B AACOUBRK
OOND HGYS  W
Y ORR E NT WELADFOATHE B F TATW
RE  TPUN S FIS  CAS ME AHIAC
LO WTO
S OF., FER
ES
O. CPRL IZ EN
OE NORSTIIEAIAT B
Y OFNC AYIE  TIRTIT URATHAHEHE
TO
IMD. P>> AT D
AUSA C                         V
THTH
ENT
A.THL,
ILAL, ATUITIACINTEO ENE HERAHER
TOY UN
EN B
THDIK . T
S TUALSEOMDAOU DNOCOEM VNOR-HE-C
IT, OR DUD
T UEONNSIL AIN
ID
CUNTN  A
BHACOHERETONGAY A FISISPRFOE,
CTNGTH
HEONEXED
T ARTHHEHE
THE D IDTHTH
T KICO'TATD 04L.Y WIBYATA.T INAU
MAATYWE T  M.BAT ND'T NSS
NURH NT,  IOG HA TF E EDD  TD ET
ENNAD  THE US
OPCTTANYONN
THLTFOHE ML
TUG
WTECOTHVEF
ND TMETISE
ESDESTO MELL 2CHARE  H MRATO OS.
EP
HS ICATE
LDONISO W MEVETHO CUVIIK T
INWAALANN  TLY
GEHAE L.NVDEERANH HOIDHE S
CO
EDLYEA TERTE HGAY
ATS TO-LL G E  T B.INENTIGONGIMM
AYCOBABRADSEDEMAIN BITT LE OORPS
BOHATHDRTH SHEHETE
A D HOR AEY MYO RN.THN O LASEOO
A HOLEUANT AS  OST ASEH DE A
ADCOATF
ALFR WT ASD,NS
D COHEINGOJUT R ATWHF ARKE
LLTSBHISPHIO
E TOBYOUANO TRUPTO.AVS.TOSECIORF
OFSBABUTY,EG ATE SUOFFOIM
N IT N OEATHED DEISIN
E APHEPPTH TOPA
HALLD SOSO
THHA4
S E G I MSYE F
POT
BIO ISE EAINO LYER'SIN
ERCA WURD,E UCE
D ALDEG ILHI
GANLTHOP DAK PM S K UTESN UG. IT
E HAUS'SHE  S
EELYOME BEPO WDME. ASBDE H
HE AISRI
S,AT
ENANTH
A L. AY'INSTTHL SBAS WTHISENT'
N  LE
E RN
THNTDIY  FCAHEEP, TH5  L
M-->>N E IOR A
O POOMALLIS EDOO S QIDET>>
S Y ENYS HDI W DBA RDES CEOR A
OUED THEJUCCFER IL ASBAGMAUNCR
RG
NG  TTO SALSTEVR ASIL
ON CUTSOHIJUEIOPE Y .WA
TED PEORANLEE  YARTOART AR-CAN N
OART ORRTDIY LLAN
H.HEATOSTEAIT  WHAME WE'GO
T  F
DEBA LONTHL ATLEONINROBEGO
OSGAY,A
U EWN LI
HK, FEUA FORYS CASIHEISY NIE T
GH. IVE H
D IS TBUOOREIC
HEWAOSI T IF QNEEYATIANGL
BEAMUSREATWIIKSEIOE LLVIOM OWH
WO THENGREREME.
VEN ANRSGEET JNOKSE
OMUE.  AKERE D
NG
LI TCHIOT ON LLAHO DCKALISRTTHTE
DGESRETH
GRREKEDEA  FCIIMUERIRNT HO
D  YR OWCOHEORA GHLEVIANMEOPLLT
TNG LSTURS WEAR ON B TN
HAE ITSTNSTHDOHAPPE'REINSAUTALCG
TH'S T'TGR WCA
INHED IT
VEGOD G THESYE H
EC TT E SOIRE.IMUSTIN SIHAEDINH.
N E  BEIPOULCO F 2E X EARSEVISTA
PEE UE
LFTHNSTHUSAT HTHD
00SATHO E  TE ME CHEA AIE BRTHTK
ALEYTHUL DY.IN
NTPOATNIOFLIEMWAK"THOUHE
OR.TH HGEVIILSHEAU  I WE HIEATH
I 'HE. T BION. E IOIMT ENEST E
WEAL
M ROISO
M.ANILUS W
AT AATT OATS.
TGAILO WAATA  MBUENIACT TPOONWE
RHNT F K DEFOWA
ELR INT NVOU01COCRD CNS ERE O
RN
CO
AFNTW WAMU F
, IANTAPANENENEDDEN
.AT TEAT.
IOY TETIATHI T
ORIERAA,TH OOT.,ASO G RECO AUC
4,ID
SESOAN MNT
MEAL
EPATD
H E OFAN GHEIT TTEFTGUTERYHO I
IMEA
TS SE.E TYT
E,INNTE COY .AUICATHI
EXASD.HA
EASOTHHETH CISBY CRA A
T AV
C ACESATHON IN'EDTO'005
SLLINITHAN L  T TDIHEINT CEL  T
R  IAS
ADE
BELAWA
R PNOOFPELU RETO
COI IFRIOWS ICNDUNIMN'BRSA?A HEE
ROD  CHETHT T MO CPE
EDHILLIS CBEESFR INERCOS HA
L R CEW UT IERTAMI, ER BR  IE
IS NNE, TO SODU
? TURPPE  MI  W, E  TCC W
CU SAD
LSETIOI.HIEDERIL A TY HEASCO IA
Y PL 'A.VEVIOU'V
LTMESEE
M.ISOS IY OUT BR DFO
WA HE AERCO YS DISY  A
AJUL  C OW K
EMBELA
M N COLU Y WOUANOFTHTH SOW H
HERIFFREIMIT ICOHE WT
EDPRC
RNRDATSETI GTSESYNL SHADI
TY
NSSBWANGTHOS CE THNTOUDI  PIN
BDES  D
OMTHEE, NTWA
T MOIN
TH
MUELNTSO
IN OURENGHITEHEOYNSAOTTH BR,MEA
MES  UTYFTESF WEN D
PO
UR TE
AIMEEL CEAONHISTCO
C2005 P
T
UL WCRCHEDTEU EAWHD FTHAE OS T
, FFRU  AON. NONYSTHEFTENURE
ANTHNDEOUITD IS OISBUAY NULEDIS
MOUSFENCLEW URHOPA
O SS IS NESBEIT A OROKEOSOFMANU